hey youtubers it's Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's arrow flash Q&A thankfully I
had some more time so I was able to
actually do a Q&A for this week's
episodes a lot of you started asking
some specific stuff about the mid-season
crossover so I'll try to answer some of
that too those two episodes will air
December 2nd and part 2 the next day on
the 3rd so I might do something extra
special whenever we get closer to
question time careful for spoilers in
case you haven't seen this week's
episodes so here we go question number 1
Trek video asks do you think that
Harrison wells is someone from the
comics is there someone he's trying to
stop and do you think he'll get a scene
with Oliver where he says something
about his future
so just because this it allows me to
answer like a billion different
questions that everyone had it'll be a
little bit longer my answer to be a
little bit longer yes I definitely think
Harrison wells is someone from the
comics I think Andrew Kreisberg Geoff
Johns Greg Berlanti
all the other people riding on the show
made some smart moves and did the comic
book rebirth story while changing some
of the details enough to maintain some
mystery so the people that had read the
comics wouldn't automatically know
exactly what was happening regardless of
who Harrison wells actually is I think
he's a time traveler that chose Harrison
wells as a name as an homage to HG Wells
in the classic time machine book so it's
a comic book character but he's using a
fake name here the people that I think
he could be from most likely to least
likely and remember he killed Simon
Stagg in cold blood he has ice running
through his veins so he's not a good
character rule superheroes out number
one
Ava Barth on professor zoom then impulse
abracadabra then a version of the rival
the original reverse flash those are
just my top picks they could totally be
someone else so your second question who
is Harrison wells trying to stop I could
probably talk about this for an hour
just about how time loops and the
multiverse could explain a lot of what
Harrison wells is doing but short
version the newspaper with the crisis at
the end of episode 1 very important it
says the Barry Allen flash disappears
I think the reverse flash or one of the
reverse flashes went back in time to
erase Barry Allen's future and was
successful and Harrison wells is trying
to fix things the timeline I think we're
seeing unfold on the show right now is
Harrison wells going back to make sure
Barry Allen does not disappear
so Harrison is guiding Barry Allen so
he'll be able to defeat the
reverse-flash the one that's
all over the timeline the big question
though is if Harrison wells is training
Barry Allen to defeat the reverse-flash
why is he doing that if he's going to be
releasing Gorilla Grodd doing all these
other evil things killing people why
would he want to help Barry Allen I
think he wants to protect Barry Allen
because he is a Oh Bart Thawne who
idolizes the Barry Allen flash in the
comics in the future gains the powers of
said flash but then does something
really bad that leads to the creation of
the hunter zolomon zoom and zoom is the
one that's messing with the timeline so
Harrison wells still wants to become the
flash in the future but in order to do
so has to make sure that Barry Allen
becomes the flash first so he's trying
to prevent hunter zolomon for erasing
all that from happening I know there are
no characters on the show right now
named hunter zolomon I'll explain that
in a second so if that sounds confusing
I think there are two versions of the
reverse flash on the show right now one
of them is messing with the timeline in
a bad way the other one is trying to
prevent that and Barry Allen is caught
between them without knowing it it's
just a mixture of my theories along with
some of the other best theories I've
seen it's like they're taking all the
comic book things from the flash rebirth
story mixing and matching names but
keeping a lot of the story beats episode
9 is called the man in the yellow suit
so that's gonna be the first time we
actually see the reverse flash like when
Barry Allen learns about him for the
first time here's what I think is going
on so I'm gonna put up a spoiler tag
even though this is just a theory I
don't consider it spoilery just in case
so here we go I think they're giving
Harrison wells professor zooms storyline
and they're giving Eddie Thawne hunter
zolomon
storyline they're just mixing the names
to throw people off
okay so let's boil apart over to answer
your question about Oliver having a
scene with Harrison wells yes I think
that's gonna happen when they do the
first part of the crossover when team
arrow goes to Central City they're gonna
have scenes at STAR Labs so I think that
Oliver will get a scene with Harrison
just like Felicity got just keep your
eyes peeled for Harrison wells dropping
Justice League Easter eggs question
number two vince asks who do you think
made Roy's suit Diggle with the sewing
machine maybe that's funny but I
actually think that Oliver contracted a
private company just gave them
specifications I don't think anyone on
Team arrow physically made it
I do think Flo
he probably helped design it a little
bit but mostly I think it was just
oliver behind the design remember during
season 1 when oliver was trying to get
info on Merlin's dark Archer arrows and
Felicity tells him they're custom-made
by this really obscure private company
it means that he along with Oliver
probably both order their stuff custom
in Batman Begins Christian Bale even had
that scene where he and Alfred we're
talking about ordering his Batman
facemask and the bat shape throwing
stars it's just one of the benefits of
being a super rich super hero or super
villain you just could custom order
anything you can think of I think that
Brandon routes character is one of the
few exceptions to this rule he has a ton
of money but he also has the technical
expertise to make his own tech suit no
word on which episode that's gonna debut
in but it's sounding like it's gonna be
the second half of the season if they're
just starting to tease the Black Canary
costume question number three Malec says
do you think the cupid freed or killed
the guy at the end so you're talking
about arrow I think that she definitely
killed him in the comics she emulates
Oliver by trying to solve crimes the
twist is is that she kills all the
criminals that's why she appeared at all
the crime scenes in this episode she's
just tailing Oliver trying to go to the
places that she knows he'll show up
question 4 Sam asks what do you think
the big reveal will be in episode 9 okay
just to clarify episode 8 is the
crossover episode braving the bold
episode 9 is the mid-season finale it's
called the climb and Alex Kingston is
gonna be guest starring as laurels mom
again like she'll be back on the show in
terms of big WTF reveals what I'm hoping
for is Rachel Golan Starling a tease of
the atom and black Canary costumes
Chyna white and katana follow-up and a
full explanation of who killed Sarah not
necessarily why just the who part that's
a whole lot of stuff but those are all
the biggest reveals I can think of right
now think back to the final scene from
season 2 episode 9
we got the reveal of Slade being the big
bad in present day and the birth of the
flash so I think we'll see the birth of
a new superhero either the atom or Black
Canary
maybe both and a big villain reveal we
already know it's Rachel Ghul so he'll
probably do something crazy and one long
shot Sarah's killer I don't think this
is very likely but what if Oliver was
the one who killed her and he was being
controlled by someone else without
knowing it the unreliable
nature of memory was a big theme in this
week's episodes so Oliver could have had
his mind messed with by one of the
villains that would probably beat like
the biggest WTF I could think of Oliver
being the killer question number five on
she gasps do you think we'll see the
Lazarus Pit based on the way the
producers have been talking about
superpowers I think that anything like
that would be done on the flash not on
arrow
for instance Ray Palmer the atom they
said that there aren't any plans to make
him shrink down on arrow they said that
if they do end up doing that they'd
shrink him down on the flash just
because of the nature of each show flash
equals superpowers arrow equals crime
drama so all the really crazy stuff is
gonna happen on the flash and just to be
clear they haven't said they're not
doing the Lazarus Pit they could still
totally do it in the future but if they
brought someone back I feel like they
bring back Tommy question number six
with CEOs if the flash is supposed to
deal with time travel do you think we'll
ever see a crossover with future
versions of team arrow or Justice League
characters so this season I don't think
so I think they'll just keep it as
simple as possible I don't think we'll
see too many people beyond Grant Gustin
and the reverse flash whenever they do
any time-travel stuff I do think we're
gonna see Easter eggs for Justice League
stuff though like Harrison wells
newspaper and we'll probably some verbal
references but I'm not expecting to see
like older versions of Oliver or
Superman or anything like that it's only
the first season so you know next year
or season 3 season 4 they could totally
do multiverse or other crazy time-travel
stuff question number 7 j-mo asks do you
think we'll see Talia al Ghul it's
totally possible but Warner Brothers in
DC have this really weird thing where
certain characters are off-limits
mostly Batman and Superman Talia does
appear in a lot of the animated movies
so I don't think we'll see her this
season the same thing totally happened
with Brandon rouse character originally
they'd planned for him on the show to be
the Ted Kord Blue Beetle but Warner
Brothers up at the top said they had
quote-unquote other plans for that
character so they changed it it made
brain and Roth the Ray Palmer atom
instead again they didn't say they won't
ever do Talia they're just not doing it
right now because they have Anissa and I
am a huge fan of Katrina law I think
she's doing an amazing job she's an
amazing character on the show thank you
so much everyone for so many questions I
think that covers all the biggest stuff
that you guys were talking about but
here's some more details about the
crossover episode The CW's released some
official information
so first off Captain Boomerang is going
to be the reason team arrow goes to
Central City and vice versa the reason
that flash comes to Starling in part two
the reason the first episode is called
flash versus arrow is because a
metahuman in Central City messes with
Barry Allen's mind
it's supposed to be rainbow Raider or
chroma however you want to think about
him like I said I'll try to do some
extra special stuff whenever that all
goes down so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and follow me on twitter and
facebook for updates just like normal
all those links are in the description
so if for some reason you don't see any
of the annotations just check they're in
the meantime do not forget Cupid crazy
stalker next week so you can click here
to catch up on this week's episode and
click here to catch up on this week's
flash episode thank you so much for
watching so let's all give each other
box and glove arrow to the face
you